[Music]
okay
um thank you so uh
i would like to again say hello to
everyone
so today we are meeting for this uh
webinar
to learn more about biomedical data
science and drug discovery
so this program will introduce
participants to the application of data
science to important challenges
in clinical and pharmaceutical
application especially and we will be
using practical examples that will cover
genomics transcriptomics and structural
data
so this collaborative program is
designed for students
by pine biotech usa far by academy india
farmer toppers
india and pro biotechnica india so
before we
let you know more about what we will be
covering in the session
just to learn about why we are doing
this so
right now we live in a world that is
recording data
every day so the healthcare data related
to clinical trials
electronic uh medical records such as
emrs
and then genetic information then care
management databases
then you have billings and then you have
internet research and social media
all sort of data so the data that is uh
that is related to health care is
growing massively
and at the same time it pose it poses a
challenge to the community of students
scientists and also researchers so this
challenge is
also an opportunity to learn and
discover from this vast amount of
information
that is now available publicly so that
is one of the main purpose of doing this
program
so after working for the last eight
months with a group of experts
from academia and industry leaders we
are really we were really excited to
bring this program to the students
where you you have an opportunity to
learn about different
omics data types and then relate and
then
learn from the examples that how this
can relate to the
real data data driven drug discovery
pipeline
and learn about these diseases and
indications
so this uh summer program that has been
uh
conceptualized by our partners and pine
biotech
so to tell you more about pine biotech
so pi biotech is a us-based company
that provides resources solutions and
training for research and education in
biomedical informatics
so we have been developed developing an
innovative
approach to incorporate bioinformatics
training
educational materials and biomedical
specialization for universities
companies and top research labs around
the world
so our team is working with academic and
industry
industry partners around the world to
adapt and utilize our training resources
for the need of
universities professional development
programs and also for school education
and to tell you more about other
partners of the program
fab academy faba academy is a special
wing under fab organization that focuses
on grooming the students of the
university
nationwide and make them future ready
and
about farmer toppers so pharma tapas is
a pioneering
institute committed to provide refined
education to pharmacy
aspirants for preparing for postgraduate
pharmacy entrance exams
as well as giving them opportunities to
learn from data science
and application of data science in kami
informatics and application of data
science
in biology the other partner is provide
technical research private limited so
the provider technical research private
limited is on a mission to equip and
empower every students and faculty with
latest technologies
and tools to create an edge from others
so the company strongly believes in
serving society and quality work
so uh for this for this program all of
us have
come together to bring you best of the
resources best of the opportunities
to learn about biomedical data science
and drug discovery
so the second phase of the program where
we are going to start learning about
a very important data type that is
transcriptomics
data type so let me tell you a little
bit about
this transcriptomics data type so in the
last decade
transcriptome based analysis has been
one of the most utilized approach to
investigate
human diseases at molecular level so
i mean you can understand the importance
of this technique
in human health so through these many
expression studies
many molecular biomarkers and
therapeutic targets have been
found for several human pathologies
and to talk more about omics logic
education
research and the application of gene
expression in biomedical research
we have uh none other than uh our ceo
uh elia brodsky so i'd like to now next
invite uh ilya
to talk more about the biomed
application of gene expression in
biomedical research
over to
and thank you everyone for joining
today's session
as mohit already mentioned uh i will be
speaking a little bit more about this
data type
what transcriptomics is and what we will
be covering in this upcoming program
but i also want to give you a sense of
what kinds of practical
assignments and tutorials you will have
access to and show you a little bit
about how this program is going to work
so as we are getting started and before
we jump into transcriptomics
i want to ask all of you to log
in to our omixlogic portal because we
will be using this login to
show some demonstration later in the
session
so you can go to learn.omicslogic.com
maybe you could post that link in there
so this is what it looks like
this is a portal that combines
everything that you need to start
learning about bioinformatics
starting from conceptual understanding
of the logic behind
different data types and their analysis
to
big data processing tools that you can
leverage to actually analyze your own
large data sets
and integrate them together learning
coding and
different statistical and machine
learning techniques so that you can
manipulate your data and extract
meaningful insights
and then also introduces you to a number
of curated projects
some of them will be going through in
this program
so once you are registered and you can
let me know
in the chat box uh thank you mohit for
posting that link so once you have
uh registered the way you register
here it's a free registration right you
don't need to pay for anything
you just go to login here you will see
i can already log in because i have an
account but you can create an account
right here
and it's just a very simple sign up you
can also
use one of your social media platforms
right here to log in and create an
account but once you log
in you will be able to see some of the
resources that we'll be utilizing in
today's session because we wanted to
make it
a practical experience for you to be
able to try some of the things that
we'll be doing in the full program
okay so please let me know once you have
registered and signed
in uh i will be just giving a couple of
minutes for everybody to complete this
step and
once you are logged in you will see that
you can complete your profile if you
wish to do so
and some of the resources i will be
speaking about them in just a second
and so please let me know once you're in
you can
uh let me know by putting number one or
logged in
signed up or something like that in chat
and that way i will know that some of
you are
already registered uh and i'll be able
to move on
okay so i see that approximately 10 of
you have already
signed up and that's great okay please
let me know once you're all
signed up and all right thank you very
much
okay so what what is this portal the
omics logic bioinformatics training
portal
is currently serving over 10 000 users
in 30 over 30 universities across
five different local chapters and so we
have representatives
in the us in israel sri lanka india
nigeria mexico
ghana mexico and others and so we're
very excited about
recently putting in a lot of effort to
redesign a lot of the materials that
we've been
using because we believe that this kind
of
bioinformatics training should be
accessible to people around the world
and uh hopefully you will appreciate how
this works in today's webinar
okay so i see that many of you have
signed up great thank you
so the omixlogic portal provides some
free resources that you can get started
with and so after today's session you'll
be able to navigate through the
different resources that we have
they include some training materials
data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive
tutorials that we'll be leveraging in
the sessions in this program
and the way that this program is
structured is we will have
sessions just like we're having today we
will join zoom
we have a communication platform on
slack
dedicated to this particular program so
there you will have access to all of the
members of this community as well as our
mentors
that you can interact with ask questions
there are some self-study
self-guided study materials that we'll
be leveraging
in between sessions because we won't
have
too much time to do all of the practicum
together
but you will get assignments and then
during the sessions we will meet again
and review some of those practical
assignments which will be done
either on the tv info platform which i
will introduce you to so everybody that
has
created an account on the learn
omxlogic.com portal
we'll have a demo account today that you
can start using to kind of explore the
platform
but also we will have a lot of practical
assignments using
r and python and i will show you how
that works today as well
now what we hope and our whole objective
for the learn
omixlogic.com portal is to provide
participants an opportunity to develop
independent research projects and the
reason why this is so critical is
because i believe that the education
system
around the world is focusing on
providing a lot of theoretical value
and not enough comprehensive project
based learning and so
this portal is focused on project-based
learning
and we have been privileged to work with
hundreds of students that have developed
independent research projects using
their
own data sets from public domain data
from ncbi
tcga and many other different projects
all right great thank you everyone for
joining now
just before we move on i also want to
mention that i know that
many of you are likely joining our
session today because you saw something
on social media
and we have a group we have a group on
linkedin
where we post a lot of opportunities for
internships
jobs in the pharmaceutical industry in
in research as well and we have a lot of
experts that are actually able to
provide mentorship and guidance to some
of you that are interested to develop
your career so
before we move on um i do want to
mention that this is
a perfect opportunity to share with you
this group of professional students
and researchers that you can interact
with on linkedin
and build your career i also want to
mention that we have a group on facebook
as well
also called omixlogic data science
bioinformatics and biomedical research
this group also has a lot of
participants from around the world over
2000 members
so you're welcome to join that program
as well and we regularly post there
a lot of information about resources
projects
and other types of opportunities that
are coming up
okay so in this program i am going to be
sharing a little bit of a background
information
um okay so the slack channel we will get
to that in a second
we are actually going to go through the
registration process
at the end of today's webinar but before
we do that
i will kind of share a little bit why we
decided to
make this program available online
so for the past uh probably uh three to
four years we have been working with
many universities around the world
offering in person training to students
faculty and professionals in
bioinformatics
data science and other elements of data
analysis
and these interactive sessions that we
saw work so well online we wanted to
kind of
translate that experience to online
where people could benefit from a
practical experience
gain some skills but also develop
research ideas
and translate those research ideas to
real research projects and so as a
result
we have experience working with hundreds
of faculty
researchers clinicians and students and
so what we are excited about
is the opportunity that big data
provides for people with
all kinds of backgrounds including
engineering
biotechnology biochemistry biology and
life sciences in general
to be able to leverage this wave of
big data that we are living through
today and so
as you probably all know and mohit
already mentioned this
big data in biomedical research kind of
became a thing
around 2015 2016. so a lot of people
started thinking about big data the
problems and the opportunities that they
have brought
to the scientific community primarily
but also business-wise
and so many companies as a result of
seeing this opportunity
started developing tools and resources
to
integrate data and allow for
user-friendly processing of data but i
think what we have all
kind of left aside is that at the center
of this kind of data analysis
integration and decision making stand
people
and so our company is very highly
focused on this
part of this data analysis challenge
and this is really to bring in more
people
to be able to use these big data
processing tools and resources
and make sense of this data to be able
to apply them
in a meaningful way and when i say all
of these people i really mean
that we need to cover people that are
lab technicians
that need to generate more and better
data we're talking about people that
developing algorithms and new methods of
analysis that need to understand where
the data came from and who it's going to
be used by
and we need to empower people that make
decisions which are clinicians
and management that need to make precise
decisions about
what to do with the data knowing the
whole story of data generation
processing and analysis and so that's
why
we provide this omixlogic training as
a user-friendly experience that you can
enter
into and understand the logic behind
analysis
and then learn about the specific tools
that you need to
use in a research project
okay so let me talk a little bit about
why
we are talking about transcriptomic data
in the context of drug discovery
drug repurposing and personalized
medicine
so as you know bioinformatics plays a
critical role in modern drug discovery
repurposing biomarker screening and
design
of personalized treatment regimens and
so many industries and research labs are
actually seeking out experts that are
knowledgeable in omics data processing
analysis and integration
and there are many different challenges
as well as opportunities
in being able to integrate analyze
and turn this data into a model that
could be used to design further
experiments
now a lot of this is based on omics
data and the term omics actually means a
lot of different types of data
and so this program is going to be
focused on transcriptomic data
but the program that we are a part of
today is
covering several different elements of
data that i think are important to
understand
so one example is phenomics and this
means
phenotypic data that can include cell
morphology
the way that cells shape right different
cells have very different
shapes and they are dysregulated in
different ways
we can also talk about genomic data
right so the sequences of nucleotides
and amino acids typically referred to
as genomic data epigenomic data which is
a field that has been growing
very fast since about 2007 2008
where we see an increase in the
appreciation of how translation of
sequences to
mrna and proteins is an important
component
of non-hereditary regulation
of genomic sequencing data
and finally what we will be focusing on
in this program
is the transcriptomic data and so this
program
on transcriptomic data analysis is an
important part because it provides a
real
in-depth view of how we can use
gene expression and isoform expression
patterns for discovery of biomarkers
for understanding of drug targets and
for being able to
perform analysis of
drug function based on expression of
mrna in different forms so
in this program which is called rna
sequencing
for drug discovery and repurposing we
will look for
how people use transcriptomic data to
link
targets to diseases validate these
targets and explore their variation
in the natural systems biology and so
i think that this really brings into the
spotlight
this new era of drug discovery where
transcriptomics could be used for
discovery of
new compounds and complex molecules like
proteins
that can control disease through the
regulation of gene expression
that essentially mimic the mechanism by
which our bodies
exert regulatory control over a range of
normal
and disease functions and so to speak a
little bit about
why next generation sequencing and what
this term
means and how we can use specifically
this kind of data
let me briefly talk about the history
behind next generation sequencing
and other forms of measurement for mrna
and this will help us see why we can
actually use
not just any type of mrna measurement
tool but
specifically next generation sequencing
so as a method of measuring rna
translation transcriptomic studies can
help detect
mrna expression inside the cell as an
accurate alternative to membrane
protein expression detection which
allows for molecular precision
in diagnostics and even development of
treatment based on molecular pathways
so what you can see here is the
expression of the her2 surface protein
which could be a measurement a detection
of that
protein essentially tells us something
about the property of the cell
and about the in the processes
inside the cell or subcellular molecular
processes that are so important for
understanding of
that tissue condition and potential
response to drug treatment so
when we think about our ability to
detect
such protein surfaces there are actually
several different techniques to do that
and before we get to rna sequencing we
can talk about one of these technologies
which is
microarray technologies so the
microarray technologies
allow us to hybridize sequences of
mrna so actual transcripts in these
flow cells that then we can extract rna
from cells or tissues
and then see which ones bind together to
these
small sequences to measure abundance of
specific molecules that we are
interested in
now as opposed to microarray next
generation sequencing
actually has revolutionized the way that
we can look at transcriptomes because
they provide us with so many uh
novel insights about what's actually
going on
one we don't have to perform a
preparation technique that creates the
assay
we just measure all the mrna that is
present
inside the cell and then we can analyze
what kind of alternative splicing events
are happening so what types of isoforms
are being generated
what types of genes are being expressed
and then how can we combine or look
separately
at these two different types of data to
make informed decisions
about the types of samples that we are
looking at
so what we'll talk about in this program
is our ability to
leverage this kind of big data
and see the significance of mrna
expression
in the context of data integration
which is really the frontier that drug
discovery drug repurposing and
personalized treatment
deals with so
what's important here is that you will
find many
interesting and important biomedical
projects that can leverage
rna-seq data for diagnostics and cancer
biology
understanding for disease classification
and patient stratification which are so
important for clinical trials
and understanding of real patient
populations that need to be treated
as well as single cell and tissue
composition so we will be able to look
at
how single cell and different types of
immune cells different types of tissues
actually represent a heterogeneous
composition of
cells with different properties that
need to be deconvoluted
for us to be able to apply meaningful
drug discovery and screening
as well as biomarker and precision
medicine targeting
of novel treatments so here are a couple
of
examples of how people have reported
on ability to use rna sequencing
and big data for drug repurposing
and personalized treatment so here you
can see
how based on our understanding
of specific patterns of
mrna expression we can integrate data
with phenotypic data right so
essentially we take comics data and we
combine it with phenotypic data
and based on our understanding of the
way that these treatments actually work
we can then design better treatments or
similar treatments for drug repurposing
in this example you can see how this
type of big data approach
has been used to speed up the
translation of treatment to the clinic
from a from the starting point not in
the lab
but skipping through the lab and
actually using this big data to identify
important targets and similar conditions
that could be targeted with
existing drugs and so those are some of
the primary things that we will focus on
data-driven discovery using big data
sets that are available
in the public domain repurposing of
existing treatments to treat conditions
that are very
similar to other ones based on their
mrna expression
and patient classification where we can
look
at different types of populations that
could be stratified
for more effective treatment the way
this program will work is it will cover
these six
important topics we will talk about
tools
and resources for transcriptomic data
analysis so we'll talk about
what this data represents how is it
generated
and how to process so that we can have
structured data
that we can work with we'll then look at
processing of next generation
data using bioinformatics pipelines so
how do we build pipelines what are these
pipelines what are the steps in these
pipelines
how do we perform pre-processing mapping
and quantification
then we'll talk about analysis
normalization and visualization of gene
and isoform expression
then we'll talk about an introduction to
big data mining clustering machine
learning and predictive analysis
we'll talk about analysis of single cell
rna-seq data for tissue specific
expression
deconvolution from bulk rna-seq
and specific phenotyping of cell types
and then we'll talk about how to apply
all of these tools in a meaningful way
to a number of curated data sets so
we'll show you some examples which i'll
talk about today
that you can actually look through
now importantly i'm sure that many of
you have experienced
this overwhelming feeling when you're
coming to a new topic
and somebody tells you that oh you can
learn this in about a week
and you're thinking i don't know so many
elements of what you're talking about
that i don't understand how all of this
could be covered in a week and so
to explain how this will work let me
show you
first of all the schedule of the program
and then i'll show you some examples
of what the actual training will look
like
so the first link that we will go to is
the program link
for transcriptomics program
okay so please navigate with me
to this link this is where the
overview of the program sessions and the
schedule
is found so you can see here a very
short overview of the whole program
it's a video and you can also see right
here
the different topics that will be
covered and their schedule so right here
you've got the calendar
and you can see where those sessions are
found
now here you can also see some of the
supporting
kind of resources that we are going to
be providing you with which includes the
training
the asynchronous coursework that you can
look through
uh mentorship so i will introduce you to
one of our mentors in just a minute
you will be able to collaborate with our
team as well as
between yourselves as groups you will
have access to big
data processing and analysis tools on
the cloud so you don't have to worry
about
what kind of a laptop you have or maybe
you don't have a lot of resources
on your own computer as well as project
support so we'll introduce you to some
curated data sets
and we will give you some guidance on
how to analyze these data sets in an
effective way
now down below you see here just a
couple of uh
testimonials of people that have
previously completed our training so you
can
kind of see what those people have been
able to gain out of this
program and we also are very focused on
making these programs
as affordable as possible so this is
already compared to
industry level pricing is very
affordable
but even on top of this we are providing
specific
scholarship opportunities for those of
you that are interested to join
and are really dedicated to learning the
resources so if mohit you could also
share the link for the scholarship
application
those of you that want to receive a
financial assistance and scholarship we
do have those available as well
down here you will find some of the
coursework that is actually included in
the
synchronous resources that we will
provide and just to give you an example
i want to go to
this link which is a very introductory
course that you will find on called
bytes and molecules
and so this course right here i'm not
going to play the full thing but you
will
see here that there is a very
gentle introduction to some of these
complex topics that
many of you might be familiar with or
maybe you have heard about it
but maybe you don't have enough kind of
a
technical overview of what all of these
terms mean so we have
a number of very introductory courses as
well as
some of the more advanced courses like
for example you can see
this project on liver cancer from
the cancer genome atlas using big data
okay so let me just get to it in a
second
down here you will see that as a result
of completing some of these resources
you will gain a certificate of
completion or a certificate of
excellence so the certificate of
completion is by just
joining all the sessions and performing
the assignments that you are going to be
getting
during those sessions a certificate of
excellence is going to be given to those
of you that are able to develop an
independent project
and showcase that project as the result
of your work
and so you will have special recognition
and a feature of the program
so that you will gain a lot more
exposure if you're looking to advance
your career
showcase what you are able to do to
people
from the industry or from academia this
is what you want you want to demonstrate
that you're able to
find an interesting topic in a project
and perform the analysis independently
with a mentor so that you can identify
some meaningful biologically
interpretable
insights in this kind of big data so
that is an opportunity for those of you
that want to
stand out and to help you achieve that
goal
we are going to provide you with
everything that you need to get started
and grow
which includes analysis of
big data and so that's what i want to
come to next
okay so let's all go to
our big data analysis platform which is
called server.t
bioinfo okay so this is a platform
that allows you to have access to over
five
terabytes of storage and
you can analyze data with a lot of the
publicly available data sets
using high performance computing so you
can actually
leverage some of the computational tools
and infrastructure on the cloud but run
those same methods you're probably
familiar with
now all of you that have registered on
the portal
can actually perform this demo that i
want to do together with you now
so please let me know once you're on
this
link server that t-bio info
so let me know by putting something in
the chat so i see how many of you are
here
and if you created your account you
will be able to use the same password
that you used when you were registering
on this portal okay so here on this
platform it's the same password
as you have on the comics logic portal
okay so i'll just give it one more
minute how many of you have already
joined this portal you can now log in so
once you're logged in
you should be able to see your email
address right here
that shows you that you have been
registered and you have access
okay so i know that we have at least 20
people today
that are here that have registered on
the portal
you should be able to to have access
so once you're there please uh put in
something in the chat box so i know that
you're
with me all right excellent to my
those of you that are just registering
right now you can actually hover over
some of these
uh sections right here to see what they
combine
what they offer you can hover over these
eyes
okay great so we have four or five
people ready
all right great so here i i will show
you just a couple of examples so that
you understand how
easy and fast it will be for you to get
started with this
uh with this program so those of you
that are here
you can see that rna-seq chip is one of
these top
sections right here you can press on
this drop down arrow and we will take
one of these demos
to show you how the pipeline actually
works
okay so let's take this first one demo
rna-seq
cell line project this is one of the
projects i'll kind of explain in just
a minute here and you will see that the
pipeline consists of some of the tools
that you might be already familiar with
star bwa bow tie
sailfish htc dc 2
etc so each button here represents an
algorithm
if it doesn't have anything on it it's a
publicly available
script that you can download somewhere
else if it has this little town
sign that means it was developed at the
tower bioinformatics research center
and you will find some explanations
about these as we go along so you can
click on start
here you'll see an overview of what the
rna-seq pipeline
actually seeks to do it first starts
with
removing technical artifacts from the
shore
sequencing reads then we will perform
mapping onto the reference genome or
transcriptome
and after that we will quantify the
expression levels of genes and isoforms
to understand
structure of data to perf to get
structured data that we can
do downstream analysis on
once i've clicked on the first step i
now have different buttons
highlight that means that my selection
is limited to the buttons that are
highlighted
so let us make a very quick pipeline we
will do some pre-processing
using trim-o-matic what is trimmermatic
it trims technical elements from
sequencing reads preparing them for
mapping so before we do mapping
we eliminate those sequences so here you
click on ok
that will actually eliminate bridge
amplification using pcr
so this is some kind of a technical step
inside the sequencing
process that could result in technical
artifacts
for our downstream analysis so we want
to eliminate that
for highly expressed genes after that
we can map our announce our prepared
data
on the reference transcriptome now how
many of you can tell me what is the
difference between the genome
and the transcriptome
okay those of you that want to become
mentors this is your opportunity to show
us how much you know about this what is
the difference
between the genome and the transcriptome
okay hershey is saying transcriptome is
mrna
genome is the entire dna excellent great
so her sheeta talk to us after this if
you want to be a mentor
you've got you've got an opportunity you
can send us your
resume so here is what we will perform
is mapping on the transcriptome which
means that we want to analyze how
we map onto the regions that are already
present in the express genes and
isoforms
so this is going to be using the gtf
file that contains the beginnings and
the ends
of all of the exons that are spliced
together to produce a transcript
so now we perform this mapping and
after that we want to prepare a table
of expression okay so what is the table
of expression a table of expression is a
matrix that contains gene expression
values but in a data frame that contains
the header which is the names of our
samples which we can organize into
groups by
phenotype as well as genes which are
typically going to be an
ensemble format so here we will perform
this rsm expression table and then we
can just simply click on
end and you can see the full process
from beginning to the end and now you
have also some
available outputs right here so let me
pause right here and let me answer some
of the questions that i've been
mentioning and i've been seeing in the
chat and i didn't have time to address
okay so um
first of all what type of tools are we
going to be teaching so all of these
tools that we use right now are open
source tools
and they are hosted on the cloud you
don't have to use them on the cloud you
can use them on your own computer if you
would like to
but we are going to be for the sake of
time using the big data processing side
here on the platform just after we
complete this
i will move on to the coding part so
that you can also appreciate
the training in r and python that we
will also include
in this program okay so hopefully that
answered your question right there
um and i hope that the the person that
had a question about the
um the schedule um you will first of all
hear more about this
and um then if you have any questions
then we can
answer that as well okay so now we have
our table of expression you can see that
we have genes
and isoforms so once we have this data
it's structured data it's not large data
sets anymore this is condensed now we
have
a lot of features but we don't have to
process
individual reads on a huge genome right
so this data has been
prepared so what can we do with this
type of data
let's just let us now go to our
learn platform so you can go here into
this section just by clicking on courses
and i will show you what you can start
doing with this type of data
to gain insights about how gene
expression
can show us differences between
phenotypes
so to do that we can go
to a course called transcriptomics so if
you just type in here
transcriptomics
so you can see here in transcriptomics
that all of the detailed steps
on how the data is generated what are
the
objectives of sequencing how do we
process and analyze this data
what are some of the statistical tests
that are being used
and all the other topics are going to be
covered here
and then you will get an introduction to
some of the methods
for for downstream analysis
of this type of data and so one of the
things that i want to take you to
is now a a tutorial on
differential gene expression so i'm just
going to
put this link here in the chat box as
well
you will see that now that we have the
table of expression we need to learn
how to organize our data into a data
frame
that is ready for statistical analysis
and visualization
using ggpr and so here you will see
how we create a data frame how we place
it into an object
and then how we can plot different plots
to find differentially expressed genes
and the cool thing about this is that
you can actually run this code
right here in your browser so you don't
have to
necessarily install all the different
kinds of rstudio and the packages on
your computer to know
how this works right because one of the
major objectives here
is to understand where does this fit in
to this
overall scheme of things how do you
actually use
differential gene expression to get a
biologically interpretable result that
you can speak about
in terms of pathway analysis and
biological function
so right here i can run this right here
in the
in this little practice console
i will get my output so you can see that
i have an output this has completed
and you know whether it was done
correctly or not
so here we have a very small
output we can look through and read our
code to understand what it is
and we have a plot that shows us
differentially expressed genes
as well as provides us with a table
and in other tutorials throughout this
course you will find how to
do different types of visualization for
this table and how to do downstream
biological
interpretation so now what i want to do
is
once you've understood how this works we
hope that we have
eliminated any questions about how so
quickly we can get from
learning about the next generation
sequencing technique to then being able
to
analyze and then being able to apply
different statistical analysis
tools as well as biological
interpretation i want to actually
introduce you
to one of our mentors to speak about her
background so that you will appreciate
the kind of support that you will be
getting as you go
through this program so i want to pass
it on now to dr harpreet kaur
she's a bioinformatics trainer she has a
phd in bioinformatics and she will be
one of the mentors
in this program
thank you
hello everyone my name is sharply i have
a phd in bioinformatics
let me give you some glimpse how
bioinformatics can be
helpful in identifying signatures for a
specific disease condition
like here i am giving examples from my
doctor's research work
so my phd research work was on biomarker
discovery for the diagnosis
and the prognosis of the liver cancer
using bioinformatics
so but inspired me to study the liver
cancer
so it's the high mortality rate of this
malignancy
and the lack of precise biomarker that
can la
that lack of precise biomarker
specifically that can
diagnose liver cancer at an early stage
worldwide liver cancer is considered as
sixth major cancer
in terms of incidence and third in terms
of mentality
often at times liver cancer is detected
too late
for an effective treatment so another
factor that contribute
to our outcome of the liver cancer
patient is the frequent reoccurrence of
tumor
after the treatment so with keeping
these concerns in mind
i have framed different objectives
that can address these concern using
bioinformatics techniques
for example in the first project
we have used last scale transcriptomics
data
to identify a diagonal diagnostic
biomarker panel for the hepatocellular
carcinoma
so in this study we employed 30 data
sets containing nearly 4 000 samples
to elucidate transcriptomic signatures
for the diagnosis and the prognosis of
the liver cancer
employing various statistical and
bioinformatics techniques
in the second project we use
transcriptomics and methylation data
to identify a biomarker tunnel for the
steel classification of hepatocellular
carcinoma
here we use tcga data of 350
samples and elucidate 51 features and
that include 30 rna transcripts and 21
methylation cpg sites
using number of data mining techniques
in this study the particularly the name
based model
classified early early and late sample
of
scc with nearly 79 percent accuracy
in the next part of the project we use
transcriptomics data
to scrutinize diagnostic biomarker
panels for the calendula carcinoma
which is another major liver malignancy
in this study we employed nine data sets
containing
350 clean your carcinoma 130 edges in
non-tumorous
9 90 fcc samples
to identify clunger carcinomas specific
transcriptomic signatures
implementing number of machine learning
techniques
like extra tree svm random forest logic
logistic regression etc
so in conclusion we have identified
a universal platform independent three
gene based biomarkers
that can predict scc patients with high
precision
and also purchase significant prognostic
potential
then we identified a three gene based
chlangiocarcinoma specific
transcriptomic signature
that are capable to discriminate cca
from scc and the normal samples with
nearly 90 percent accuracy at last
we have identified a biomarker panel of
51 features
that include 30 rna transcript and 21
methylation cpg sites
to predict hepatocellular carcinoma at
an early stage
so in my current role i am curriculum
developer and research consultant with
fine biotic
i am assisting participants who learn
about data analysis
machine learning and visualization in
application to large dataset used in the
biomedical research
so to provide hands-on training and to
make participants familiar with the
approach
to design and complete research projects
we are continuously designing different
research process
using publicly available data based on
the studies
published in high impact journals
thus we have a collection of research
projects
where you can learn how bioinformatics
can be applied in the field of inter
different uh diseases including oncology
infectious diseases
based on the publicly available data
to drive biological and clinical imp
features from that data
so for example let me give you one
example
uh one of such preset here
we have explored different omics layer
that is
rna mi rna and clinical and demographic
data
employing multi omics data integration
approach for the liver cancer patient to
find out
molecular signature that are associated
with the clinical phenotypes of the
liver cancer
as one of the major challenge with the
malignant conditions
uh that a single omics layer is not
sufficient
to design highly efficient biomarkers
those multi ohmics data types can fill
that latina
and fill a will facility to design
efficient signatures
but then another major challenge the
integration of those multi-omics data
type
either you need to develop an individual
pipeline for each data type
then you will find an approach or a
method that can integrate them together
so for this you require a either
highly computational or a bioinformatics
skill
so to remove these obstacles various
multi omics data integration tools like
snf i cluster plus o2 pls
are integrated on the t by input server
where you
users just need to provide input data
set and can
easily perform various types of
multi-omics analysis
by just clicking on options like already
already ilya has shown you so in this
project we have also
implemented these multi-omics data
integration tools
so finally we are trying to understand
how
multiomics data integration analysis can
provide us the holistic picture of this
lithium lethal malignancy and also how
they are associated with the diverse
clinical
phenotypes like tumor stage risk factors
race is gender of the reasons
so participants can explore this project
during the upcoming program
to get a better understanding
so beside that there are number of the
research
fellows who have completed their
research projects in the field of
oncology with the pine bioinformatics
research fellowship program
so the first one miss ucha parikh who is
post graduate
from india and completed her research
projects on identification of biomarker
to differentiate between neural cells
and glioblastoma employing publicly
available data
using different tools that are
integrated on tv
so our another research fellow
dollar who is an undergraduate student
from the turkey
recently completed her research project
entitled long non-coding rna
and therapeutic target in chronic
lymphocytic
leukemia using publicly available data
and integrating various tools from the t
band to server
then we have kala umadi maru who is a
phd student from the
mexico city and completed her research
project entitled classification of
triple negative breast cancer cell lines
by
gene expression analysis of the
transmembrane protein
using machine learning algorithm based
on the cell line data
employing multiple machine learning
tools
that were integrated on a t1 for server
so i am looking forward to being your
mentor in the upcoming
saskatoonics program now i would like to
pass this session to miss sunalika
to talk more about this program
and if you have any question you can
please go ahead and post your queries in
the chat box
so thank you so over to you
thank you mom i'll be just sharing my
screen in a while
yes thank you sir
good evening everybody i am pursuing
masters in bioinformatics from punjab
university chandigarh
and currently i'm a research fellow at
pine biotech my research interest lies
in omix data sciences computer aided
drug designing
and for marco informatics so today i'm
here to share my path to computational
biology
and how bioinformatics shaped my career
so as a student it all starts in 12th
must have happened with all of you no
doubt so i took medical
and like any medical aspirin my only aim
was to get into
mbps i worked a lot hard but destiny
could not get a government
seat i had uh like i ha
i had heard a lot about bioinformatics
as the most promising field and the
subjects
gained my attention and i got a seat for
pursuing bachelors in bioinformatics on
azad punjab university
i learned a lot gained a lot of insights
and
about many fields and then came the time
for my masters
so i started exploring about more fields
i thought let's explore some other
fields in the masters
and somehow i started thinking about
other fields like stem cell engineering
genomics genetic engineering or the
biomedical sciences
but then my professors made me realize
about how vast bioinformatics
is about how it comes under all the
domains like how it covers all the other
domains and
how pursuing masters in bioinformatics
could help me
do research in whichever domain i would
want to
so that made me pursue masters in
bioinformatics
and then came my second year of masters
and i was very much interested to take
up some or the other internship program
and do some sort of hands-on analysis or
learn more about how
actually industry works and what skills
are required
but what happened in uh in my second
year it says covet happened
so i started looking for opportunities
online and i was fortunate enough
to uh find out the pine biotic website
so i found a great deal of courses over
there there were many projects over
there
and also i was surprised to see that
they had got
the rn python code integrated in their
server
itself so i took up the courses i
learned a lot of them and then
i in january i was fortunate enough to
get a research fellowship and i started
my research project my master's
degradation project on liver cancer
with them itself and just in the span of
three months
i was like i could finish my project
and academics has designed the program
such that
we need to take six months to do our
project but just with the help of the
server i could do everything in just a
matter of few months
so many a times people actually ask a
question
by bioinformatics and where it stands
today
so actually i just wanted to discuss how
important the field bioinformatics
is so bioinformatics is actually the
collaborative study
which integrates a lot many fields so it
has
biology computer science maths
biochemistry
statistics chemistry engineering and
data science obviously that's the most
upcoming study right now right so
it's not like that that bioinformatics
has no scope or or
it's like a smaller part of some or the
other field but
actually what i think it is the father
of all
because all the main branches they come
under what
bioinformatics so getting a hands-on and
getting yourself trained with all the
skills of bio
informatics is like the most important
thing right now
and as we all have been discussing that
in our uh academics what we face is a
lot of theoretical part of concepts
because
our syllabus first of all doesn't get
updated timely
and it focuses more on the theoretical
path so this is what i'm talking about
the
education system i'm not blaming any
system but
yes it's like that uh so yeah we need to
actually look for more of uh trainings
and uh we need to train ourselves with
the upgraded skills
so that's where pine bar deck helped me
a lot
so first of all my research project i
was very much confused which topic to
take because it happens with almost each
and every
uh student i believe that whenever our
projects are about to start we think
okay which topic we should start with
how what to do how to do
and things like that so the mentors at
find biotech they were so pretty helpful
to me
like they helped me with what topic to
choose
so uh ilyasha harpreet so they
actually hit me with my topic what
should be my research question they help
me frame each and everything
and they were with me at each and every
point of my research project whenever i
faced an issue they were there to help
me
so mentorship it's amazing and then the
best part is
that we don't get such pretty big labs
or the instrumentations which is
required to carry out the research
at a great level and i used to believe
that just because
my institution can't afford uh these
expensive
uh labs and machines that means that
i might somehow lag behind
others but no actually find biotech
provided
that server to me to carry out whatever
analysis
in the world i can think of right so
uh all my research project analysis was
uh through the prime biotic server and
what i did in my project was
i repurposed drugs based on the
transatomic data of hepatocellular
carcinoma cell lines
so i needed to carry out a lot many
things let it be machine learning
or to find out the differentially
expressed things see where
the clusters are present and also then i
had to integrate a lot many
visualizations to understand my results
in a much better way
so that's where uh t by info came to my
rescue
uh so yes it's a great platform and
moreover
if you are interested to learn more
about others projects first because many
times if you you are a
non-bioinformatics student
you might be confused about what to do
and
like what the topics are like to know
more about the existing opportunities
right
so there are a lot many projects
integrated on the server which you can
like go
and have a look at i understand what
they did
how they did what was their methodology
and uh the research process
yes and also there are many like demo
pipelines which you could follow
and moreover the best of all is that
there are
like the bestest of the trainings and
webinars where each and every assistance
is there like you can see yourself today
itself uh like each and everything was
sold though not in that much detail
because yes there's a lot a lot to cover
so we need time to do that
but yes up to a great extent it was so
yes
i feel myself fortunate enough uh
to be a part of pine biotech to have
done my
master's dissertation with pine biotech
even in the covert times
and yes so i thank you all i thank the
team especially
who helped me a lot to complete my
project thank you now i would like to
pass it on to dr mohick
okay thank you sonalika
and also like to thank our preet
and idia so there was a question on
variant analysis kobe 19 so i wanted to
share this
maybe i'll just go back to the
presentation
okay so uh hello again uh my name is
mohit mazumdar and i'm one of the global
representatives of pine biotech
and in my current role i'm collaborating
and working with academia and industry
to provide support for bioinformatics
research and
education so along with our hard working
and efficient team we have been able to
work with more than 30 universities
for the past couple of years for
research-based programs and helping
thousands of students to develop
understanding of data-driven research
and life sciences
so in this program what we'll be doing
is that we will be utilizing some of the
top rated online tutorials using the
learn
portal this has the smart tracking
as well as curated data sets designed
for
great learning experience so after that
uh
to tell you uh about the program so in
this program we will combine
online sessions self-guided study
material and practical assignment
for an immersive experience that has
proven to be very effective in our
well-known and respected omics logic
programs
so we will learn about important
concepts within biomedical research such
as infectious diseases
cancer research and learn about
immunology of infection
molecular disease markers and stages
and how these diseases can be diagnosed
and treated
so uh we will be talking about several
bio
bioinformatics methods uh such as
processing
uh of rna-seq data and like learning
about differential gene expression
and more and finally we will look at the
sample projects and learn how to create
our own project projects with the
bioinformatics method using the public
repositories so by learning about these
major concepts
you will be able to equipped to start
your
own project
so about the uh schedule so the upcoming
program like
uh we already have seen the schedule and
we'll go back to the page where you can
download this entire schedule and more
descriptive
one but uh for this uh presentation i'll
just take you through the sessions
really quickly
so that you will understand how this is
i mean how this is going to be
so the upcoming program will focus on
ngs transcriptomic data analysis that
include uh performing downstream
analysis and applying data science
techniques and machine learning methods
so we will have almost um i guess four
weeks
to discuss the various aspects of rna
seek data analysis
and how this field of bioinformatics is
uh
is amazed uh is continues it's continued
to evolve and amaze us all
so to start with the first session
will be about uh you know learning about
mrn and library preparation mapping
mapping on the transcriptome using uh
algorithms such as
top hat high set bowtie 2g
sailfish so we will be discussing and
telling you that what this algorithm
does and
we will show you how to run this
algorithm so what to expect
from that analysis so that's why i think
tbi info platform plays a very important
route which was discussed earlier
so the first session will be on 19th may
and we'll be looking forward all of you
to join the session
and learn from us and learn from the
resources and come up with a project and
do your internship all of that
so the second session will be about uh
processing transcriptomics data which
will be on 21st uh 21st
may so here we will be discussing
strategies
of mapping exon and junction detection
and then techniques such as
normalization and quantification
and this is all covered in
transcriptomics one
so the transcriptomics courses will be
uh will be available for those who are
joining
and along with the projects but this
course will give you a
great overview of how this entire
ngs analysis is you can start and
you know expect results so after that
on 24th may we have the session on um
project and also it is more about you
know reviewing
so uh uh so we will be reviewing a
publication so as we
said and discussed and dr harpreet also
showed you that
uh that uh this is a more of a research
based program
so this in this session we will be
learning about modeling precision
medicine
so here the example is breast cancer
cell lines and the application of
machine learning
so this is a paper uh by demian at all
modeling precision medicine for breast
cancer
so this paper talks about 70 different
breast cancer cell lines and 90
different therapeutic
agents so drugs so this project also
include
snp data so microarray data rna-seq data
transcriptome which is
and then exam and genome-wide epigenomic
data as well
so our focus here will be to understand
about you know precision medicine
uh that actually revolutionize the way
patients are treated
by using precise molecular information
that provides you know reliable
indicators on
the effectiveness of the treatment so uh
i mean that is one of the major
objective of the
program so in this project we will uh
when
you will be first learning about the
publication and how they
did it and then we have a project uh on
this publication
so in the project we will leverage cell
lines from
human breast cancer tumor and study
that how they integrate with the
other mixed data and the response to
various cancer treatments so what is the
response to the drugs
so as a result you will learn about
various omics data types and how to
integrate them associate them with
phenotypic changes so the response to
the treatment would be the phenotypic
change here
and we will be using uh sophisticated
machine learning algorithms obviously
because it's a
complicated multi-dimensional data so
after that uh on 26th
we will be learning about uh loading uh
these uh
data sets into the into the
python and r and then how can we use
that and prepare matrix and data frames
and create variables and stuff like that
so after that we will be learning about
normalization
and preparation like uh what we can do
for uh to create a pipeline and what
what we expect from the results from
that pipeline
so uh also like removing zero nonzero
and log scale transformation after that
we will be learning about how we can do
this like
in and see visually so doing the box
plots
scatter plot histograms heat maps uh
after the transformation doing it on the
coding
side of things so after that we will be
learning about
exploratory analysis and are in python
so here we start about
uh pca uh so from descriptive statistics
to machine learning
so here we will start about exploratory
data analysis and
we will be using coding as well as the
t-bind for platform
and then uh the uh you know one of the
major
objective of this program is to learn
about uh how
the changes in expression uh
you know affects the phenotype
so differential gene expression is one
of the tools that is
used for this so we'll be learning about
d sec uh
algorithm hr and volcano plots
uh and all of that so that would be on
fourth june
and then we have about the next part
as regression analysis so here because
we are doing comparison
we are making groups and then groups
have different
characteristics features so we will be
learning about t
test and uh anova regression and factor
regression analysis
to get into deeper getting deeper inside
of regression analysis and this is also
very much uh covered in transcriptomics
too so even if you miss the session
or if you want to prepare ahead of the
session so you can do that
so so that you can make most of the
session so this will be also
available for the participants to do uh
the courses first
and then attend the sessions so that
could also be done
and then we will learn about biological
interpretation and in the context of
single cell so
uh how you can do single cell analysis
and how you can come up with you know
uh cake pathway annotation for
differentially expressed gene
uh to understand about the biological
process molecular function
and uh all of that so
by this time you have learned about the
different techniques and how you can
apply this to different
uh different kind of data sets and also
how to understand the biological
interpretation how to interpret the
biological
how to connect it with the biology so
after that
the next step is to you know learn about
the application of this technology into
different
areas of research so the next session on
11 june is about that
so here we will be discussing about
literature review compiling
a data set developing analysis plan and
doing that entire you know
transcriptomics data analysis and how
that
is applicable to neuroscience infectious
disease and oncology so we already
have these projects and we already
discussed about molecular cell precision
molecular cancer modeling cancer
christian medicine but we also discussed
the tcga project
and we also have the projects on
neuroscience and other projects that you
can
learn from so during this time we will
be covering
all of that and as elia said
we will be utilizing these platforms and
resources so quickly just to tell you
that
this entire omis logic programs will be
utilizing the learn platform where you
have created a login
so i think if you have not please uh
please create a login here it's a free
login so i mean you don't have to join
the program to create a login but you
can
again if you're not joining but still
you can avail a lot of resources and
learn from the resources
and maybe once you're more comfortable
you can think about
what training you would need but if you
are uh
interested and interested in learning
this so i would recommend you to join
this program
now it's a great opportunity uh to join
this because we have multiple
collaborators
and different expertise and we'll be
covering a lot for this summer
because summer is the time where you
will have time and we will also have
time
so here uh the second platform that will
be utilizing is the tbi tbinfo platform
uh so which you saw and the third
platform would be the coding platform
and then we will be applying it using
machine learning multivariate analysis
we will be using data mining and
classification algorithms such as
hierarchical clustering
decision trees random forest support
vector machine
and also
svm and so yes support vector machine
lda linear discriminant analysis so we
have all of them
in on the platform and then we will be
practicing the data science tutorials
using the code platform
and we'll be applying that for
visualization and downstream analysis
so this will be the part of this entire
program all of the access will be the
part of the program
so you will be getting access to the uh
to the different platforms as well as
the tutorials from where you can learn
on your own from your browser because
you don't need to even install
uh these um these uh
lab this programming tools and also like
the softwares
so out of this entire entire program you
will be able
to learn and understand from the
literature and you'll be able to
understand the
steps that is required that are required
to do the ngs data analysis
with uh reproducibility so there will be
a constant accuracy
and you'll be guided by the experts who
have worked throughout
their career and knows in and out most
of the things
but obviously research is challenging uh
each time you get a news question
but however like we have quite a bit of
experience working throughout
as india said so we'll be helping you do
these steps
understand from these steps and try to
make the most from the
learning that you get so
uh in this entire process we will be
learning about
rn python has said statistical
techniques how to manage and analyze
data develop communication skills
about how we can present this
information that we have created by by
the form of a slide deck
by the form of a video or by interacting
with us like in
in in one of these sessions so the
sessions that we will have
are with the participants and with
the trainer so you'll have a lot of
opportunities throughout that time hours
of time to
discuss your own problems and come up
with
uh solutions so we'll be doing all of
that
and to registration about registration
and downloading all of this
at one place so let's just go again
to this site the transcriptomic side
that we all
went before and then learn about the
process of the registration so here i
have the site open so
[Music]
if
if anyone can share
the link so let me share it
yeah there you go so this is the site uh
for registration
if you have already logged in so your
name will come up here your name will
reflect
so uh once you're here you can request
for more information
like joining a webinar like the one
you're doing
and you can also start your application
so once you start
your application you come to this place
beginners intermediate and advanced
now uh you have three different
levels to choose from so in intermediate
in the beginners you will get
all of this uh that we discussed today
the difference between intermediate and
beginners is that
here you can request for special
one-on-ones
mentor support to help you with any of
your questions and if you feel like that
you need additional support and that
would be good for you so that option is
there on mentor on this
intermediate option and then for the
advanced option is for someone who would
want to work on their own data
and would want to work on uh using
uh the t by one for research platform so
the research platform enables you to
upload your own lab data
which is not public publicly available
and you will get a research license to
run
your analysis and get support for that
so
that's the research license and then you
can sign in and check out so in addition
to all of this
uh till tomorrow
there's a special code that you can
apply so you can get a 30
discount on all of that all of the above
so the registration
fees will be reduced the scholarship is
30
for all of you which is an early bird
scholarship so
you can apply that 30 scholarship and
this will be
for available for 105 which is around
700 rupees in
indian currency so please feel free to
let us know if you face any problems
i'll just show you that
how you can apply that maybe quickly
so i'll start with logging in and once i
log
in i will be able to apply it
for the payment process
so please uh feel free to let us know if
you have any
other uh questions related to what we
covered today
and uh and again i mean you
if you if you have not joined the groups
please feel free and go and check the
groups here
the the group on linkedin and the group
of group in
facebook where we keep on posting about
uh our upcoming programs free webinars
and a lot of resources
free resources and good resources that
can
you can utilize and learn from so
let me just check if if i have it open
because actually
i don't use safari so maybe i can show
you
here or maybe you can let us know
in case you feel any problems you know
while doing this
but anyways uh please uh let let us know
if you have any questions and we will be
happy to answer those
now before uh we end this session
so
yeah idia is sharing because yeah it's
not
loading i guess
yeah so here you can click on
right now and then uh you get this
add promotional code here
yeah so ngs30 uh
well in any case maybe you will email
the code for those that are interested
in so that they can do it
sure yeah
so if there are any question please let
us know
and we will be able to answer those
so is there any possibility of doing
postdoc and transcriptomics based
drug designing so yes i think bss
there are a lot of opportunities that
are available
on this sort of training and projects so
i see there are a lot of projects on
transcriptomics data analysis
and also like if you have much
experience a little bit of experience
uh of working on these data sets
yourself
and exploring that what are the
challenges that are there
so those are the questions that you get
during the interview so it is better to
get a hands-on feeling
of how this data is applied to different
kind of research
because it's just not like this but it
has like the
omics data or bioinformatics has a lot
of application in all of the fields of
areas of research so i think more uh one
or uh
now then it will be useful for you if
you can
do that so yeah i mean just let me i
have actually we have emailed you with
all of that information if you have
registered through the link
but just like give me one second let me
confirm the code with
with all of you so that you can apply
that
to this because the code is going to
expire uh tomorrow
so yeah it's ngs30 i guess we will we
will be checking it and emailing you
again so please look for emails from us
uh we will be emailing you from uh
marketing at the rate pine dot bio
and you can also email us if you have
any other
questions at movie that pine dot bio
and marketing at pine dot bio and
sonalika if you can write your own
email address as well
so uh please feel free to reach out to
us
and let us know if you have any problem
and thank you for
joining today's session and uh be here
with us and listening to us i hope that
today's session was useful for all of
you
and with that i would like to conclude
today's session and i hope to see you on
19th
um have a great rest of the week
thank you everyone
you